one and now that I've given lots of
speeches we had a bunch of high school
principals come and see me and they said
mr. Strickland what an extraordinary
story and what a great school and we
were particularly touched by the flowers
and we were curious as to how the
flowers got there I said well I got him
a car and I went out to the greenhouse
and I bargained I brought them back and
I put them there you don't need a task
force for a study group to buy flowers
for your kids what you need to know is
that the children those deserve flowers
in their life the cost descents adapter
buzz the gesture is huge and so in my
building which is full of sunlight and
full of flowers we believe in hope and
human possibility that happens to be at
Christmastime and so the next thing
you'll see is a million dollar kitchen
that was built by the Heinz Company
you've heard of them they did all right
the Ketchum business and I happen to
know that company pretty well because
John Heise was our u.s. senator who was
tragically killed in a plane accident
had heard about my desire to build a new
building because I had the cardboard box
and of putting the garbage bag and I was
walking over Pittsburgh trying to raise
money for this thing and he called me
into his office which is the equivalent
of going to see the Wizard of Oz John
Heinz had six hundred million dollars
and at the time I had about 60 cent he
said but we've heard about you and heard
about your work with the kids and the X
Steel Workers and we're inclined to want
to support your desire to build a new
building and you could do us a great
service if you would add a culinary
program to your program because back
then we were building trades program and
said that way we could fulfill our
affirmative action goals for the Heinz
Company and said senator I'm reluctant
to go into a fields I don't know much
about but I promise you that if you'll
support my school I'll get it built in a
couple years I'll come back and we'll
add that program that you desire in
central Hinds sat very quietly he said
well what would your answer be if I said
I'll give you a million dollars
I said senator it appears that we're
going into the food training business
and John Heinz did give me a million
bucks and most importantly he loaned me
the head of research for the Heinz
Company and we should kind of bard the
curriculum from the Culinary Institute
of America which in their mind is kind
of the Harvard to cooking skills and we
created that gourmet cooks the program
for welfare Rhodes in this million
dollar kitchen in the military City I
would never look back I would like to
show you now some of the foods that
there's welfare mothers do
in this million dollar kitchen that
happens to be our cafeteria line that's
puff pastry day why because the students
made puffed pastry and that's what the
school way every day but the concept was
that I wanted to take the stigma out of
food that good foods not for rich people
good food for everybody on the planet
and there's no excuse while we all can't
be eating it so at my school we
subsidize a gourmet and lunch program
for welfare mothers in the mill the
inner city because we've discovered that
it's good for their stomachs but it's
better for their heads because I wanted
to let them know every day in their life
that they have
at this place I call my center we have
students who sit together black kids and
white kids the government discovered is
you can solve the race problem by
creating a world class environment
because people will have a tendency to
show you what class behavior if you
treat them in that way
this is examples of the food that
welfare mothers are doing after six
months in the training program no
sophistication no class no dignity no
history what we've discovered is the
only thing wrong with poor people is
they don't have any money
what happens to be a curable condition
it's all in the way that you think about
people that often determines their
behavior that was done by a student
after seven months in the program done
by our very brilliant young woman who
was taught by our pastry chef I've
actually eaten seven of those baskets
they're very good they have no calories
that's our dining room it looks like
your average high school cafeteria in
our average town in America but this is
my view of how students ought to be
treated particularly ones who have been
pushed aside
we trained pharmaceutical technicians
for the pharmacy industry we trained
medical technicians for the medical
industry and we trained chemical
technicians for companies like bear and
Calgon Carbon and Fisher Scientific and
Exxon and I will guarantee if you come
to my Center in Pittsburgh and you're
all invited you'll see welfare mothers
doing analytical chemistry with
logarithmic calculators ten months from
enrollment in the program there was
absolutely no reason
why poor people can't learn world-class
technology what we've discovered is you
have to give them flowers and sunlight
of food and expectations and herb is
music and you can cure a spiritual
cancer every time we train corporate
travel agents for the travel industry we
even teach people how to read the kid
with a red stripe was in the program two
years ago is now an instructor and I
have children with high school diplomas
that they can't read and so you must ask
yourself the question how is it possible
in the 21st century that we graduate
children from schools who can't read the
diplomas that they have in their hands
and the reason is that the system gets
reimbursed for the kids who they spit
out the other end not the children who
breathe I can take these children and in
20 weeks demonstrated aptitude I can get
them high school equivalent
no big deal
that our library was more handcrafted
furniture and this is the arts program I
started in 1968 remember I'm the black
kid from the 60s you guys lifesaver
ceramics while went out and decided to
reproduce my experience with other kids
in the neighborhood the theory being if
you get kids flowers you give them food
and you give them sunshine and
enthusiasm you can bring a rag back to
life I have 400 kids from the Pittsburgh
Public School System that come to me
every day of the week for arts education
and these are children who are flunking
out of public school and last year I put
88% of those kids in college not my
average over 80 percent for 15 years
we've made a fascinating discovery
there's nothing wrong with the kids that
affection and sunshine and food and
enthusiasm Herbies music can't care for
that I want a big old black man of the
year and education of beat out all the
phd's because I figured that if you
treat children like human beings and
increases the likelihood they're gonna
behave that way and why we can't
Institute that policy in every school
and every city in every town
let me show you what these people do we
have ceramics and photography and
computer imaging and these are all kids
with no artistic ability no talent no
imagination
and we bring in the world's greatest
artists Gordon Parks has been there
Chester Higgins has been there and what
we've learned is that the children will
become like the people who teach them in
fact I brought in a mosaic artist from
the Vatican an african-american woman
who had studied the old Vatican mosaic
techniques and let me show you what they
did over the world these were children
the whole world had given up flocking
out of public school and that's what
they're capable of doing it was
affection and sunlight we teach
photography
and this is examples of some of the kids
work that boy won a four-year
scholarship and the strands of that
photograph
mr. gallery we have a world-class
gallery because we believe that poor
kids need a world-class gallery so I
designed this thing we have smoked
salmon at the Argo place we have a form
of printed invitation and I even have
figured out a way to get their parents
to come I couldn't buy a parent 15 years
ago so I hired a guy who got off on the
Jesus big time he was dragging guys out
of bars and saving those lives for the
Lord and I said bill I want to hire you
then you have to turn down the Jesus
stuff a little bit to keep the
enthusiasm I can't get these parents to
come to the school he said I'll get them
to come to school so he jumped in the
van and went to Miss Jones's house and
said Miss Jones I knew you wanted to
come to your kids aren't opening but you
probably didn't have a ride so I came to
give you a ride and he got ten parents
and the 20 parents the last show that we
did 200 parents showed up and we didn't
pick up one parent because now it's
become socially not acceptable not to
show up to support your children that
the Manchester craftsmen's guild because
people think you're bad parent and there
is no statistical difference between the
white parents and the black parents
mothers will go where their children are
being celebrated every time every town
every city
I wanted you to see this gallery because
it's as good as it gets and by the time
I cut these kids loose from high school
they've got four shows on their resume
before they apply to college because
it's all up here you have to change the
way that people see themselves before
you can change their behavior and it's
worked out pretty good up to this day
I even stuck up another room on the
building which I'd like to show you this
is brand new we just got the slide done
in time for the TED Conference I gave
this little slide show at a place called
the Silicon Valley and I did all right
and the woman came out of the audience
she said that was a great story and I
was very impressed with your
presentation my only criticism is your
computers are getting a little bit old
and I said well what do you do for a
living
she said well I work for a company
called hewlett-packard
I said you're in the computer business
is that right she said yes sir I said
well there's an easy solution of that
problem well I'm very pleased to
announce to you that HP and a furniture
company called Steelcase have adopted us
as a demonstration model for all of
their technology and all their furniture
for the United States of America and
that's the room that's initiated
relationship we've got it just done in
time to show you so it's kind of the
world debut of our digital imaging
center
I only have a couple more slides and
this is where the story gets kind of
interesting so I just want you to listen
up for a couple more minutes and you'll
understand why he's there and I'm here
in 1986 I had the presence of mind to
stick a music-hall on the north end of
the building while I was building it and
a guy named Dizzy Gillespie showed up to
play there because he knew this man over
here Marty Ashby and I stood on that
stage with Dizzy Gillespie on soundcheck
on a Wednesday afternoon and I said
dizzy why would you come to a black run
Center in the middle of an industrial
park
with a high crime rate that doesn't even
have a reputation in music he said
because I heard you built the center and
I didn't believe that you did it and I
don't want to see for myself and now
that I have I want to give you a gift I
said you're the gift he said no sir
you're the gift and I'm gonna allow you
to record the concert and we'll give you
the music have you ever choose to sell
it you must sign an agreement that says
the money will come back in sports too
and I recorded dizzy and he died a year
later but not before telling a fella
named McCoy Tyner what we were doing he
showed up and said does he talk about
you all over the country man and I want
to help you
then a guy named Wynton Marsalis showed
up then a bass player named Ray Brown
and a fella named Stanley Turrentine and
a piano player named Marie Hancock
and and the band called The Count Basie
Orchestra and a fella named Tito Puente
and a guy named Gary Burton and Shirley
horn Betty Carter Ponies
and Nancy Wilson all have come to this
center in the middle of an industrial
park to sold-out audiences middle of the
inner city and I'm very pleased to tell
you that with their permission I have
now accumulated 600 recordings of the
greatest artists in the world including
Joe Williams who died but not before his
last recording was done in Leslie
and Joe Williams came up to me
and he put his hand on my shoulder he
said down gods picked you man to do this
work
and I want my music to be with you and
that worked out alright when the basic
band came they the band got so excited
about the school they voted to give me
the rights to the music and I recorded
it and we won something called a Grammy
like a fool I didn't go to ceremony does
that think we're gonna win well we did
win that our name was literally in
lights over Madison Square Garden you
and jazz rock mr. drop live and we
recorded them and got nominated for a
second gravity back to back so we become
one of the hot young jazz recording
studios in the nine states of america in
the middle the inner city was a high
crime rate that's the place all filled
up with Republicans if you drop the bomb
in that room either white got all the
money in Pennsylvania cuz it was all
said there including my mother and
father who live long enough
and see their kid though that building
and there's desi just like I told you he
was there and he was there Tito Puente
and a Bellini Jim Hall were there they
recorded with us and that was our first
recording studio which was the broom
closet and we put the mops in the
hallway and re-engineered the thing and
that's where we recorded the first
Grammy and this is our new facility
which is all video technology and that
is a room that was built for a woman
named Nancy Wilson who recorded that
album at our school last Christmas and
any of you happen to be a March and
Oprah Winfrey on Christmas Day he was
there and Nancy was there singing
excerpts from this album the rights to
which she donated to our school and I
can now tell you with absolute certainty
that an appearance on Oprah Winfrey will
sell 10,000 CDs we are currently number
four on the Billboard charts right
behind Tony Bennett and I think we're
gonna be fine this was burned out during
the riots this is next to my building
and so I had another cardboard box
filled and I walked back out the streets
again and that's the building and that's
the model you know on the rights of
hi-tech greenhouse and in the Middle's
of medical technology building and I'm
very pleased to tell you that the
building is done it's also full of
anchor tenants at $20 a foot triple net
and though the inner city and there's
the phone
every building has a fountain and the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
or anchor taste they took after building
and we now train medical technicians for
all their system and Mellon banks a
tenant and I love them because they pay
the rent on time and as the result of
the association I'm now a director of
the Mellon Financial Corporation that
bought trayvis
and this is in the process of being
built as we speak
multiplying that picture times four and
you will see the green house that's
going to open in October this year
because we're going to grow those
flowers in the middle of the inner city
and we're going to have high school kids
growing Phalaenopsis orchids in the
middle the inner city and we have a
handshake with one of the large retail
grocers to sell our orchids in all 240
stores and six states and our partners
at Zuma Canyon orchids of Malibu
California who are Hispanic
so the Hispanics and the black folks
have formed a partnership to grow
high-technology orchids in the middlee
in a city and I told my United States in
there that there was a very high
probability and if he could find some
funding for this we would become a
left-hand column in the Wall Street
Journal to which he readily agreed and
we got the funding we opened in the fall
and you gotta come see it has been
announced
and this is what I want to do when I
grow up the brown building is the one
you guys have been looking at and I'll
tell you where I've made my big mistake
I had a chance to buy this whole
industrial park which is less than a
thousand feet from the riverfront for
four million dollars and I didn't do it
and I built the first building and guess
what happened
I appreciated the real estate values
beyond everybody's expectations and the
owners of the park turned me down for
eight million dollars last year instead
mr. Strickland you ought to get the
civic leader of the Year award because
you've appreciated our property values
beyond our wildest expectations thank
you very much for that the moral of the
story is you must be prepared to act on
your dreams just in case they do come
true and finally there's this picture
this is in a place called San Francisco
and the reason this pictures in here is
I did this slide show a couple years ago
at a big economic summit and there was a
fella in the audience who came up to me
he said man that's a great story I want
one of those I said well I'm very
flattered what do you do for a living he
says I run the city of San Francisco my
name is Willie Brown
and so I kind of accepted the flattery
and the praise and put it out of my mind
and that weekend I was going back home
and Herbie Hancock was playing our
center that I first of all I met him and
he walked in and he says what is this
and I said Herbie this is my concept of
a training center for poor people and he
said as God is my witness I've had a
Senate like this in my mind for 25 years
and you built it now I really won't
build one I said well where would you
build this thing he said San Francisco
has a chance you know Willie Brown as a
matter of fact he did know Willie Brown
and Willie Brown and Herbie and I had
dinner four years ago we started
throwing out that Center on the
tablecloth Willie Brown said as sure as
I'm mayor of San Francisco I want to
build this thing as a legacy to the poor
people of this city and he got me five
acres of land on San Francisco Bay and
we got an architect and we got a general
contractor and we got her be on the
board and our friends from HP and our
friends at Steelcase and our friends
from Cisco and her friends from Wells
Fargo and then Genentech and and along
the way I met this real short guy at a
slide show in the Silicon Valley he came
up to me afterwards he said man that's a
fabulous story I want to help you and I
said well that's thank you very much for
that what you do for a living he said
well I built a company called eBay
that's so well that's very nice thanks
very much and give me your card and
sometimes we'll talk I didn't know eBay
from that jar of water sitting on that
piano but I had the presence of mind to
go back and talk to one of the techy
kids at the center that said hey man
what is eBay he said that's the
electronic commerce Network I said well
I met the guy who built the thing and he
left me his card so I called him up on
the phone and I said mr. skull
I've come to have a much deeper
appreciation of who you are
and I'd like to become your friend
and Jeff and I did become friends and
he's organized a team of people and
we're going to build this Center and I
went down into the neighborhood
I called Bayview Hunters Point and I
said the mayor sent me down here to work
with you
and I want to build a Center with you
but I'm not gonna build you anything if
you don't want it
and all I gots a box of slides and so I
stood up in front of 200 very angry very
disappointed people on a summer night
and the air conditioner had broken and
it was a hundred degrees outside and I
started chilling these pictures and
after about ten pictures they all
settled down and I ran a story and I
said what do you think and on the back
of the room a woman stood up and she
said in 35 years and living in this
godforsaken place you're the only person
has come down here and treated us with
dignity I'm going with you man and she
turned that audience around on the pin
and I promised these people that I was
going to build this thing and we're
gonna build it already and I think we
can get in the ground this year as the
first replication of the center in
Pittsburgh but I met a guy named Quincy
Jones along the way and I showed him the
box of slides and when she said I want
to help you man let's do one in LA and
so he's assembled a group of people and
I've fallen in love with him as I have
with Herbie and with this music and
Quincy said where did the idea for
centers like this come from I said it
came from your music man because mr.
Ross used to bring in your albums when I
was 16 years old in the priory class
when the world was all dark and your
music got me to the Sun and I said if I
can follow that music I'll get out into
the sunlight
and I'll be okay that's not true
how did I get here I want you all to
know that I think the world is a place
that's worth living I believe in you I
believe in your hopes and your dreams I
believe in your intelligence and I
believe in your enthusiasm and I'm tired
of living like this going into town
after town with people standing around
on the corners with holes where eyes
used to be their spirits damaged we
won't make it as a country unless we can
turn this thing around and Pennsylvania
it cost $60,000 to keep people in jail
most of you look like me
it's $40,000 to go to the University of
Pittsburgh Medical School it's $20,000
here we'll go to medical school to keep
people in jail
do the math
it'll never work I am banking on you
and I'm banking on guys like Herbie and
Quincey and Hackett and Richard and very
decent people who still believe in
something
and I want to do this in my lifetime in
every city in every town and I don't
think I'm crazy I think we can get home
on this thing and I think we can build
these all over the country for less
money than we're spending on prisons and
I believe we can turn this whole story
around to one of celebration and one of
hope in my business it's very difficult
work you're always fighting upstream
like the salmon never enough money too
much need and so there is a tendency to
have an Occupational depression of the
companies might work and so I figured
out over time the solution to the
depression you make a friend in every
town and you'll never be lonely I hope
is that I've made a few here tonight and
thanks for listening to what I had to
say